[Musique]
alors est-ce que déjà on entend bien oui
super et bien voilà comment on m'a
présenté j'appelle robin je travaille en
cybersécurité pour vous donner un peu un
background sur moi je suis ingénieur
comme je pense la plupart d'entre vous
moi de l'autre côté de lyon j'ai fait
l'école centrale à à ecully et j'avais
une formation à la base ingénieur
généraliste
ça ricane forcément les rivalités entre
écoles dont on connaît bien j'avais une
formation d'ingénieur généraliste et
j'avais une petite tente pas tout à fait
honnête en mécanique et en énergie
aujourd'hui je travaille en
cybersécurité alors je me suis dit pas
pourquoi pas en fait après tous
l'espèrent sécurité celle de 38 yves ça
doit être simple bon et j'ai appris j'ai
appris je me suis lancé dans ce risque
j'ai apprivoisé cette inconnue qui était
mon nouveau métier est depuis en fait je
fais ça avec un plaisir assez assez fou
et on m'a dit est ce que tu pourrais
venir parler de ton métier est ce que tu
pourrais venir parler sur la thématique
embrasser l'inconnu et je me suis dit
qu'est ce que c'est que l'inconnu pour
moi et pour moi l'inconnu dans mon
métier au quotidien ça se transforme en
risque et je me suis dit basses sont
j'ai parlé c'est comment est ce qu'on
fait au quotidien dans nos métiers pour
appréhender la notion de risque l'idée
ça peut faire un grand théorème du
risque jeu par un grand conférence et
sur ridge et 15 minutes devant vous et
des cellules de donner quelques clés et
quelques informations importantes sur
comment on gère le réseau d'entreprise
et qu'on peut aussi gérer au quotidien
pour nous pour mieux embrasser cette
inconnue
déjà quand on veut définir les termes il
y en a la vieille blague de philosophie
de dire le sujet de philo qui était
qu'est-ce que le risque est la personne
qui répond le risque c'est ça bon
résultat c'est absolument faux c'est pas
ça le risque il a eu 1 0 et demi et n'a
pas eu son bac donc c'était un très
mauvais risques à prendre le risque en
réalité c'est déjà faire la distinction
entre deux types de risques majeurs qui
peuvent nous arriver et que ce soit au
quotidien ou en entreprise déjà les
risques que l'on connaît les risques que
l'on connaisse et les risques où on a du
recul historique mathématiques ou autre
par exemple j'ai prendre le risque quand
on joue au loto on sait tous que quand
on joue au loto bon à peu de choses près
on perd à chaque fois et on s'est même
modéliser de façon assez simple ce qu'on
perd à chaque fois qu'on joue au loto
compères en général cinq ans avant son
hôte mise et de temps en temps
on gagne plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros et c'est pour ça que la
française des jeux marche aussi bien
dans cette partie de rêve qui est
associé à ce risque il ya des risques du
coup qu'on mobilise comme c'est le taux
assez simple à modéliser ces lois
mathématiques il ya des risques on les
connaît par l'histoire typiquement on va
avoir des risques comme les épidémies
lyon jean pas les pandémies mais des
épidémies ou on sait que tous les ans à
peu près il ya une
par une épidémie de gastro en france ça
arrive c'est comme ça
et c'est brice que là on arrive à les
inquiéter assez facilement on arrive à
se dire mais il existe on on peut savoir
à peu près ce qu'ils valent du coup
j'avais même envie de dire on les
connaît presque et ces risques là eh ben
on a beau les mesures et parfois on va
pas les prendre en compte on va pas les
les utiliser malgré tout la vision nous
risquons à autour je pense par exemple
aux drogues et à l'alcool à l'excès de
vitesse et même aujourd'hui au
changement climatique on manque
clairement de vision sur le long terme
passe quand on parle de risque on parle
aussi forcément de bénéfices en face
pourquoi je prends des risques majeurs
n'a rarement pour avoir un bénéfice à
court moyen ou long terme dans le cas de
tous ceux que j'ai cités généralement on
comprend que le bénéfice à court terme
il existe certes c'est sympa je mâchais
la dernière voiture hyper polluantes par
contre à long terme bon c'est pas ouf
pareil pour tous qui alcool drogue à
court terme c'est sympa à long terme
généralement ça diminue notre espérance
de vie du coup on a beau les connaître
on va quand même pas les traiter
correctement et gèrerait cette partie de
traitement à la toute fin
et des risques qui pour le coup sont
même complètement inconnu ce sont des
risques qu'on n'arrive pas un tweet est
aujourd'hui qu'on n'arrive pas à
connaître du tout du tout du tout par
exemple les pandémies les pandémies on
peut tout se dire ça arrivera et des
pandémies de grippe et les pandémies de
dashan mais on n'avait jamais imaginé de
pandémie comme celles qu'on a connues
qu'il ait duré un an et demi et qui
n'est pas encore finie même dans nos
entreprises on n'a jamais jamais évalué
le risque d'une pandémie aussi longue
tout simplement parce que on s'est dit
ça n'est pas possible
iliad et d'autres éléments décrits des
risques inconnus qu'on a même si on a du
recul historique on n'arrive pas à les
mesurer typiquement les crises
économiques
où le risque de guerre ce sont des
choses que l'on ne voit pas que l'on
n'arrive pas à estimer aujourd'hui qui
prendrait en compte dans une entreprise
le risque d'une guerre et qui a trait
demain en france a priori personne et
pourtant le risque existe s'est déjà
produit par le passé
il ya un type de risque est intéressant
dans le risque inconnu c'est les risques
qui se faisait du souci de micros les
risques qui se sont réalisés mais qu'on
n'a pas encore vu et moi on s'y perd
sécurité c'est un risque qui m'arrive
assez souvent en france pour des multi
statistiques le nombre eu le temps moyen
après un incident de cybersécurité pour
s'en apercevoir c'est de deux à six mois
cercle après qu'une entreprise se soit
fait pirater il faut généralement six
mois pour s'apercevoir qu'elle s'est
fait pirater donc le risque est restée
inconnue très souvent sous-estimé
puisque tu as été piraté et pour autant
et bien présent il s'est bien réalisé et
d'ailleurs ça va être inquiétant dans
mon métier de me dire ça se trouve
aujourd'hui je vous parle et mon
entreprise s'est fait pirater qu'il sait
qui est très importante quand on parle
de risque ce qu'ont été leurs sa notion
de risques et bénéfices
avec notamment une notion d'appétit pour
moi au risque et c'est comme ça qu'on va
voir la maîtrise du risque par
l'appréhension des appétits déjà quand
on parle de la maîtrise du risque en
tant que tel il a trois composantes
essentielles qui moisson mon quotidien
la prévention la détection et la
remédiation déjà la première partie
c'est bas pour éviter qu'un risque se
produisent près avec un risque en soi il
suffit que je prévois que j'anticipe ce
risque donc là je vais tout simplement
prendre une méthode très simple de me
dire bah se risque à peu près c'est un
peu du pifomètre combien de fois par an
une fois par siècle va-t-il se produire
si j'ai un risque qui se produit par
exemple une fois par an je peux dire
chaque année j'aurai une fois
l'occurrence de ce risque en moyenne qui
arrivera
donc ça je les scories entre 1 et 6
admettons 1 1 3-10 arrive une fois par
an et après ma deuxième composante sera
l'impact qu'est-ce que je donnais comme
impact à ce risque sur mon organisation
sur mon business sur ma vie sur ma façon
d'être sur l'image de mon entreprise
auprès du public notamment dans les
piratages ce qu'on reproche très souvent
c'est la perte d'image pour ces
entreprises là oh la la perte financière
vous n'avez pas confiance
dans une entreprise qui s'est fait
pirater du coup on va mesurer son impact
est très souvent on va mesurer l'impact
financier parce que c'est plus simple
est celui qui parle le plus de personnes
facile à chiffrer moi non au budget
chaque année la journée à faire mon
budget pour l'année prochaine je sais
que je vais avoir un risque de cyber
sécurité qui peut se produire admettons
cd dvd faux chiffres une fois par an et
qui a même coûté à chaque fois en
moyenne cinq cent mille euros gk dire
dans mon budget bah en fait robin tu
prévois d'avoir une fois par an cinq
cent mille euros qui vont disparaître
donc dans mon budget je réserve cinq
cent mille euros au risque que je vais
prendre très simple est ce que toute
assurance ferait
du coup là on est vraiment dans un
scénario catastrophe vas-y mon mal
risque il s'est produit après quand on
réfléchit à tout ça on se dit mais en
fait est ce que je suis prêt
foncièrement à prendre ce risque et
avoir un appétit au risque alors il est
4 heures donc s'attendre à faire ma
personne mais l'idée derrière c'est de
se dire est-ce que cinq cent mille euros
par an c'est une perte acceptable pour
une entreprise et que me coûterait le
fait de vouloir corriger ce risque
typiquement si je vous dis que pour
corriger un risque de 500000 euros par
an il vous faut à peu près un million
d'euros pour le corriger vous allez me
dire banon va pas le corps et j'ai
surtout pas donc j'ai avoir un appétit
au risque qui va faire que je ne vais
surtout pas agir si par contre a
contrario pour pouvoir corriger ce
risque de 500 milles il suffit juste que
j'investisse 10 euros on va tout le
monde le ferait ces 500 entreprises on a
des gros budgets on a de l'argent on a
du temps et puis généralement ça ne
bouge pas nous même si entreprises
meurent bon c'est très triste j'en
serais le premier en subir les
conséquences
mais pour autant ça nous touche
personnellement à titre perso on a
exactement les mêmes réflexions et on se
les pose jamais de façon chiffrée on ne
se dit jamais bah tiens si je roule à
180 sur l'autoroute est ce que ça vaut
vraiment le coup déroule à 180 si je
fais à 180 sur un trajet d'une heure
d'être gagnée au lieu de 130 dix minutes
un quart d'heure je sais pas trop quoi
et pourquoi in fine et se poser devant
les pubs en arrivant à la maison le lien
est pas et pas incroyable et pourtant je
me suis mis en danger est-ce que ça en
vaille la peine est ce que j'avais cet
appétit au risque
et quand je reprends ma matrix
chiffré avec un score de probabilités
allant de 1,6 à un score d'un pack
talent devant les assises que chacun
définira comme étant sa propre matrice
par votre propre appréhension du risque
et votre propre appétit au risque on
pouvoir se dire je suis prêt à prendre
un risque chiffres et admettons à 12 à
chaque fois et tout ce qui est inférieur
à 12 bat pour moi c'est du risque
acceptable du risque avec je ne veux
aucune aucune maîtrise par contre un
risque qui est supérieur à 12 c'est un
risque que je devoir corriger et moi
j'ai très souvent une question
d'entreprise c'est de me dire ok
maintenant j'ai un risque j'ai scoré par
exemple à 6 c'est quoi la bonne réponse
face à un risque à 6 de se dire je ne
fais rien j'en fais encore moins où j'en
fais encore plus façon assez surprenante
on pourra avoir une réponse qui serait
dire j'en fais encore moins parce qu'un
risque à 6 quand on a un appétit à 12
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas pris assez de
risques on a fait de la sueur qualité ou
la surprotection il est très souvent
elle vient impacter le business en face
elle vient impacter notre qualité de vie
elle vient impacter notre capacité à
progresser et ça on le retrouve aussi à
titre perso ben si je ne vis pas si je
ne prends aucun risque et bien
typiquement il va rien m'arriver ni de
bien et de mal dommage j'aurais pas vécu
du coup les 111 tout ça est de se dire
quand on appréhende un risque c'est bien
de se dire déjà qu'est ce que je suis
prêt moi à accepter comme risque pour
moi pour les autres et pour mon
entreprise après comment je viens
mesurer ces risques je peux avoir
l'impact sur absolument tous genres que
de l'impact sur ce que je connais tous
les risques inconnus par essence
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à les prévoir
alors on peut se dire qu'on prévoit dans
un budget d'entreprise pour la très
incertain ce qu'on appelle du rnd risk
and opportunities l'idée c'est de se
dire que chaque année va se présenter
des risques inconnus et qu'on peut
allouer une somme du temps des
ressources à la gestion de ces risques
qui vont se produire au pas se produire
à la fin de l'année si j'avais budgété
un million d'euros pour mes risques
inconnus rien de ses produits tant mieux
j'ai gagné un million d'euros tant pis
il s'est réalisé et va au moins c'était
prévu
tous les risques car je vais pouvoir
avoir la connaissance de la maîtrise je
vais pouvoir les corriger gérer leur
détection et gérer leur remédiation mais
tant les ressources nécessaires pour
corriger le risque une fois qu'il se
sera réalisé
et mon mot de la fin sera de faire
attention à cette notion de risque parce
que on pourrait se dire ouais mais si je
réfléchis toujours au risque j'ai plus
joué au loto j'ai plus boire je peux
plus conduire je peux rien faire et ben
si parce qu'on a tous notre appétit au
risque on a tous cette volonté d'avancer
pour des bonnes raisons il faut savoir
quand l'entreprise au titre perso le
risque doit sont des composantes
essentielles qu'on devra en prendre pour
avancer et qu'il est important de le
maîtriser correctement et avec cette
toute petite astuce l'impact et la
probabilité on peut savoir du coup
qu'est ce qu'on est prêt à prendre comme
risques et sur quel site m on est prêt à
les prendre
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]